is it really more fun to be a Berliner
than a London oh well let's ask Kathryn
McGinnis from the City of London
Corporation and Nina Schick who is a
native Berliner and a European political
commentator so you've got a point as me
mr. Pete so I mean London is bloomin
expensive well thank you very much for
inviting me to answer that after London
is one of the greatest cities in the
world and that is why so many people
want to be here and so many young people
and indeed so many tech companies and
and clusters we have commerce we have
culture we have access to finance we
have open spaces and I don't recognise
us being that expensive I cycle myself
you can get around easily without
without difficulty of course we have our
issues such as housing and we're
determined to do something about that I
mean the infrastructures no Bauer laughs
I'm not entirely coming on on the
northern I'd you in the rush hour every
morning isn't a barrel of laughs well in
a few weeks time you'll be able to come
in on the Elizabeth line in the new
crossroad which will open up Suede's of
London - much quicker travel of course
as I say London so popular we have lots
of people here and we have to
accommodate that what about this brexit
issue though Catherine I mean this is
really creating a lot of uncertainty
what breaks it is creating some
uncertainty for people of course you
mentioned thousands of banking jobs
going we don't yet see many thousands of
jobs going we see banks doing what they
need to do which is to be ready to serve
their customers on day one post breaks
it whatever happens and indeed I doubt
our government as soon as possible to
look at transitional arrangements so
that we can all move smoothly through
this process I think that's actually
just as important for for countries in
both for countries amongst the eu-27 for
the businesses and people on the streets
there I urge them as soon as possible to
make clear that they access to people
because it's the great diversity of the
workforce here that has helped London
thrive but London is a great city and
it's going to carry on being that and
after the breaks it as we were before we
joined Europe what do you make of all
that man well London is one of the
greatest cities in the world but so is
Berlin and I don't think you can
credibly make the argument that London
is not an expensive city it is a very
expensive city especially for young
people such as myself and the thing
that's very attractive about Berlin is
that the living standards are higher and
of course the entire brexit process X
diets of how attractive Berlin is and
one of the main reasons one of the
things I think that's certainly gonna
hurt London is whatever the new
immigration scheme that the government
puts into place we know that the
Conservative Party has said that it's
going to stick to its tens of thousands
of target and this will really hurt
burgeoning industries in London like the
tech sector we already have a huge
skills gap domestically for the digital
economy and this is where countries or
cities like Berlin see a huge
opportunity and are trying to lure
startups to come trying to fashion
itself as a capital for tech I mean
Germany lags the UK in many respects I
mean if you look at educated Germans
they're very very lonely represented on
social media it's got very low
penetration things like contactless card
transactions I mean four and five
transactions in Germany is still done in
cash I mean it seems quite old-fashioned
in some ways absolutely that is
certainly the case but I think that and
undoubtedly when it comes to FinTech
London is the world centre however
depending on political developments
that's not to say that London supremacy
in this area cannot even flow to
different cities in across Europe and
this depends on things like the new
immigration system on things like pause
porting rights into the into the you
whether people are able to be
domestically skilled up to have these
digital skills that are needed for the
economy so I think that London though it
is leading in many of these digital
aspects especially when it comes to
FinTech it cannot rest on its laurels
and think that other European centres
cannot compete with it let me put this
to you could it this is a data from a
why Berlin startups in 2015 raised two
point one five billion euros in venture
capital funding in London it was only
one point seven seven billion Berlin's
already winning isn't well because I
have are actually that since the
referendum last year and we've had two
point four billion a venture capital put
into taking British technology companies
and that is that is price as much as it
has been putting in Germany and of
course venture capital isn't the only
form of capital and just look at the
backdrop behind you we have access here
it's it's Europe's gateway to capital
and whether that's capital for startups
or for companies that are scaling up
this is the place to be if you want to
do start your business and grow it we
also have our regulators here
and they combined and those prudence but
also support for innovation we have our
regulatory sandbox which has done so
much to give us that great strength in
in FinTech last words you need know that
they've Catherine the first word I mean
very briefly obviously London has a
fantastic ecosystem but I think that the
challenges of brexit could chip away at
some of the things that make London a
standout city for startups for example
the European Investment Fund will they
continue to invest in London at the rate
that they have done it's been vital to
startups in the city and I think that
the political challenges ahead mean that
London also has a difficult time ahead
Catherine McGinnis good SIBO thank you
thank you